- Wir müssen noch mal gerade überlegen,
wir hatten ja heute die Reservierung
für die Überraschungsmenüs,
was wir den Gästen machen.
Lukas, was hast du als Vorspeise?
- Als Vorspeise habe ich
Pulpo und Zucchinisalat.
- Okay. Und als Hauptgang,
was machen wir da?
- Was machst du für ein Fleisch?
- Ich hab Maishähnchenbrust.
- Kartoffelstrudel und Spitzkohl hab ich.
- Und dann mach ich noch
ein paar Pfifferlinge dazu.
- Ja!
- Nachtisch haben wir auch schon?
- Ah, ja, lass mal überlegen …
Ich hab Erdbeerparfait und Vanilleeis.
- Okay, ja. Klingt doch nach ’nem ...
Das wird ihnen schmecken.
Ich hoffe, die hatten ...
Sonderwünsche waren da nicht?
- Nee, bisher nicht.
Aber wenn noch irgendwas kommt –
ich frag ja noch mal,
dann sag ich Bescheid.
- Alles klar, machen wir so.
Gut!
- Heute Abend haben wir den Zehnertisch,
den haben wir als Überraschungsmenü.
Dann haben wir, glaub ich,
einen Geburtstag für vier Personen.
Die bestellen aber à la carte
und dann machen wir Glosche.
- Alles klar.
- Also Feuerwerk so ein bisschen.
- Ja, wunderbar. Machen wir so,
kein Thema.
- Und an Tisch acht
hab ich einmal Allergie gegen Salbei.
- Ja.
- …, ob da alles im Menü okay ist.
- Okay, und wenn da sonstige
Sonderwünsche kommen,
müsstest du mir dann
noch Bescheid sagen.
- Mach ich.
- Ja? Alles klar!